verehrte easyjet fans hier sind heute
wieder in berlin und bei uns ist harry
wie geht's dir ganz gut ist nämlich
einer von euch er ist ein easyjet
zuschauer hat uns geschrieben erst zu
besuch in berlin
und heute geht er mal mit janisch in die
stadt um die menschen auf der straße zu
fragen und unsere frage heute ist keine
geringere als der schönste ort in
deutschland
diese episode ist ein spezielles
geschenk für jeffrey kreis jeffrey ist
einer von unseren pattons hallodri und
jeffrey hat uns diese frage geschickt
geschrieben hey ich komme im mai nach
deutschland
ich habe eine woche zeit wo soll ich
unbedingt hin und wir dachten diese
frage geben wir doch einfach mal weiter
an die menschen auf der straße bist du
bereit ja alles klar dann ist sein
mikrofon ihr dafür schön
los geht's
travers
ich habe große frage wer sind die
schönsten orte in deutschland
es gibt so viele schöne orte in
deutschland hat es ist schwierig zu
sagen
berlin ist ein schöner ort wenn sich
richtet jetzt ja warum berlin berlin
bietet einfach viel ein zusammenschluss
von vielen menschen kann da was erleben
dort was anderes erleben hat große stadt
warum warum ist es berlin die chance
berlin ist eine sehr interessante mal
lebendige stadt also was in besonderes
kann man in berlin machen außer
klassischer theoretischer dinge ich weiß
auch das klassische museum ist zwar auch
der klassische
das ist so eine vielfalt für jeden was
dabei so ein bunter fasten ganz viele
verschiedene farben heute rot morgen
blau und übermorgen geht die schönsten
ort in deutschland
hamburg da zählt auf jeden fall berlin
dazu aber auch im südwesten gibt sehr
viele schöne orte unter anderem das
schöne göppingen und die stadt münchen
sehenswerte plätze und orte
wer hier sind die sichersten orte in
deutschland einen haben wir gerade vor
der tür
hier natürlich da wo ich herkomme
koblenz rheinland-pfalz es sehr schön
was noch in deutschland schwarzwald
schwarzwald sehr schön
bayern ist schön sachsen ist schön
berlin ist schön hamburg die küste ist
sehr schön
also wir brauchen eigentlich nirgends
von urlaub hinzufahren deutschland
können wir über den fall ist überall
schön insgesamt kölner dom der dome
warum weil ich so kirchen mark und diese
details und alles in deutschland ist in
deutschland in der vor allem stehen wir
gerade ist das brandenburger tor da
hinten mit abstand eine der schönsten
sehenswürdigkeiten in deutschland dann
aus norddeutschen raum natürlich schloss
neuschwanstein
warum es liegt landschaftlich
beeindrucken das hat eine interessante
und lange geschichte und ich komme aus
süddeutschland in deutschland
der hamburger hafen würde ich sagen
warum weil es das schön windig ist und
das sind schöne kräne und es ist eine
schöne stimmung
für mich der hamburger hafen
heidelberg als stadt ist ganz schön habe
ich studiert und ansonsten also ich bin
küsten menschen daher mag ich nord und
ausziehen
zwischen flensburg einig bis hamburg und
das nicht wenig ostsee aber und dann
einige osten über die ostdeutsche ostsee
ist schöner als die westdeutsche auch
wenn ich von der westdeutschen komme
hamburg ist fantastisch und so geht's
weiter wir leben in remscheid auch eine
reise wert weil es bergisches land ist
es einfach traumhaft schön von den
städten her hamburg hamburg hamburg
bochum und münchen seien schön warum
hamburg
was kann man da machen oder seine stadt
mit der auch mit sehr viel kultur und
sieht einfach toll aus ist einfach in
hamburg ist es einfach schönes gefühl in
deutschland unsere stadt beckum neu
bekommen haben
dortmund welche sind die schönsten orte
in deutschland die schönsten orte
leipzig ist sehr schön und dresden ist
auch sehr schön sowie münchen ist sehr
schön
hamburg ist eine tolle stadt und berlin
natürlich was noch
söderberg sind ich ganz toll und
den wald annaberg was denkt ihr
stuttgart stuttgart ist definitiv eine
schöne stadt doch auf jeden fall was
kann man in stuttgart sehen oder machen
man kann ohne auf den schlossplatz da
die sonne genießen das ganz schön kann
auch in die werra das gros dazu auf dem
fernseher wir haben auch einen
fernsehturm parks viele ja das waren
unsere antworten in der heutigen episode
tv was sind für dich auf der straße wie
fandest du die antworten die einfahrten
sind es ganz befreien
die leute mit dem ich mit ganz fröhlich
also ja das ist ein insgesamt sehr gute
erfahrung für mich und der die antworten
sind ganz hilfreich für mich als ein
besucher du hast ja auch schon mal jetzt
bist du gerade zum urlaub in deutschland
aber du hast ja auch schon mal ein paar
wochen hier gewohnt was würdest du denn
sagen ja als ultimativer tipp was
würdest du sagen wo muss man unbedingt
hin wenn man deutschland besucht ich
würde sagen heidelberg fahren halber
ganz romantisch und ganz besonders
es gibt so viele orten in heidelberg wo
man mit partner oder freuden mitlaufen
kann und es gibt auch dieser philosophie
weg wohnen kann zusammenlaufen und
entspannen einfach weg ist ja wir haben
ja das vorurteil in deutschland dass
alle asiaten nach heidelberg fahren
es ist wirklich eine wunderschöne stadt
es ist so vielleicht alles der touristen
highlights und es ist auch wirklich
nicht schön also statt also müsste
immerhin fahren das war es auf jeden
fall schon wieder für diese woche wir
hoffen ihr habt viele tipps willkommen
wir hoffen natürlich dass ihr jetzt
genug ideen bekommen hat und unbedingt
mal ein flug zu buchen und nach
deutschland zu kommen
man muss einfach mal hinfahren oder ja
natürlich ja danke dass du dabei war es
hat uns sehr gefreut wenn ihr mehr sehen
wollt schreibt unbedingt bei isar
germany hier unten und gerne dürft ihr
euch uns auch unterstützen denn unser
programm lebt von spenden das könnte
hier unten machen
bis nächste woche und dankeschön